when I voiced Prime for the very first
time I was living with my brother Larry
he was a marine and I said I'm going to
an audition I'm going to be a truck
and he started to laugh and he said he
said a truck and I said this is a leader
this is a hero and his demeanor just
changed he just went well Peter if
you're gonna be a leader be strong
enough to be gentle and I got to the
audition and I said my name is Optimus
Prime from the planet Cybertron I had no
doubt that this is what a hero should
sound like and I was convinced I was
going to get that rule
this is an emergency can you hear me
Mirage roll out who the hell was that
Peter Cullen geese and he goes deep into
Optimus Prime mode you're like whoa this
is really happening we have one last
hope Stephen Capital Jr really is
Sensational he's thoughtful he's
energetic he's moving he instills that
confidence to take the wheel
yeah baby
every Transformers movie Optimus Prime
and a lead human being are always close
and this is the first time in the film
where you see these two characters who
are trying to figure things out you
brought a human here Transformers were
eyes of the beasts has the same
ingredients that were there at the
beginning there is that Integrity
there's a dignity there's courage
it's an honor to be able to do this
character I've talked with a lot of
people that grew up with Transformers
and I don't take them for granted I love
you guys
this is Optimus Prime June 9th I invite
you to the movies